الاستخبارات التركيه تحبط محاوله الموساد
اختطاف مهندس فلسطيني طور برنامجا لاختراق
منظومه القبه الحديديه الدفاعيه واخر
لاختراق هواتف محموله يستخدمها مسؤولون
اسرائيليون العمليه كشفت تفاصيلها وسائل
اعلام تركيه ووصفتها بالاقوى استخباراتيا
خلال السنوات الاخيره عمر ا من مواليد
قطاع غزه عام
1991 در علوم الحاسوب في الجامعه
الاسلاميه بغزه وفي عام
2019 تلقى عرض عمل من شركه برمجيات
نرويجيه لكنه رفض بعد ان راودته شكوك في
حقيقه التوظيف وانتقل في مارس اذار 2020
للعيش في اسطنبول قادما من القاهره وهناك
بدا الموساد بمراقبته من كثب واجرى معه
اول لقاء مباشر عام
2021 من خلال عميل يدعى رائد غزال زعم انه
يعمل مديرا للموارد البشريه في شركه
فرنسيه وحاول جاهدا اقناعه بالانضمام
للعمل في الشركه لاحقا اوكل غزال المهمه
الى شخص اخر يدعى عمر شلبي الذي عرض على
عمر برمجه تطبيق مقابل 10000 دولار امريكي
وبعد تنفيذ التطبيق وارساله الى الشركه
تسلم عمر المبلغ من عميل اخر حمل اسم جون
فوستر في عام 2022 اوكل شلبي مهمه التواصل
مع عمر الى عميل اخر يدعى نيكولا روندا
44 عاما فحاول مرارا اقناعه بضروره سفره
الى اوروبا وعرض عليه راتبا شهريا قدره
5000 دولار اذا ما بقي في اسطنبول و2000
دولار اذا ما قبل بالعمل من البرازيل
العميل الدع معرفته مسؤولين في اداره
الهجره التركيه وطلب من عمر معلوماته
الشخصيه وارسال صوره عن جواز سفره بعد ان
اكد له ان الشركه بحاجه الى حضوره الى
فرنسا في هذه الاثناء سارعت الاستخبارات
التركيه الى التدخل وحذرت المهندسه من
السفر في ايلول
2022 قرر عمر السفر الى ماليزيا للسياحه
ولان الاستخبارات التركيه كانت على علم
بعروض العمل المشبوهه التي تلقاها عمر
قدمت له التحذيرات اللازمه والتدابير التي
يجب ان يتخذها وعليه حمل على هاتفه تطبيق
يكشف عن موقعه حتى وان كان هاتفه مغلقا في
ال8 من ايلول
2022 اختطف عمر في العاصمه الماليزيه
كوالا لمبور وتعرض للتعذيب والاستجواب من
رجال الموساد الذين استفسروا منه عن
الاليه التي مكنته من اختراق القبه
والهواتف
الاستخبارات التركيه تواصلت مع نظيرتها
الماليزيه واعلمها بموقع المهندس ونجحت
القوات الماليزيه في انقاذ المهندس عمر
والقت القبض على 11د عش
[موسيقى]
مختطفا